desde las 8 de la mañana la gente está
saliendo a votar estamos aquí en un
centro de votación de la alcaldía benito
juárez una de las 16 alcaldías de la
ciudad de mexico que se renovarán se han
instalado en todo el país más de 162.000
casillas en este proceso electoral para
renovar más de 21.000 cargos públicos
son más de 93 casos 95 millones de
mexicanos los que están llamados a las
urnas en este proceso electoral que es
el más complejo pero también el más
violento y uno de los más letales con
más de 30 candidatos que han sido
asesinados y además en la pandemia de
kobe 19 para lo cual se han dispuesto
todas las medidas de seguridad la gente
está acudiendo a las urnas con sana
distancia con cubrebocas puesto todo el
tiempo se les aplica gel anti bacterial
y han dicho que esta misma noche se
conocerán los resultados a nivel federal
son 500 curules en la cámara de
diputados federal las que se van a
renovar